all right let's answer some questions
our good friend a red zone alk who's
been asking questions all the way back
to when pft live was a digital only
project on nbcsports.com is joe burrows
biggest obstacle to success
the bengals organization itself also
will aj green be traded and who would
want him shireen your thoughts
well you know the bengals haven't won a
playoff game as just about everybody
knows since 1990 it was over the houston
oilers who no longer exist they're now
the tennessee titans sam weisz was the
late great sam weish was the coach and
anthony munoz still played and
you know all those things it's been a
really long time as siason was their
quarterback so
it is the bengals organization they
haven't been very good since 1990
and they continually do bad things but
they looked like they had done some
different things before this season they
signed some free agent they spent some
money they made the right pick at number
one overall
so they looked like they were moving in
the right direction
i don't know who age who would want aj
green
if they can get anything for him
absolutely i think you trade him but to
me
last night he just looked old i mean to
get
that many targets and he was 13 targets
and
make that few catches three catches for
for 29 yards 9.7 a catch
to me he just looked old i don't know
who would want to pay him the money
with the franchise tag on him no
guarantee beyond the season
if they can get anything for him
absolutely i say you trade him at the
trade deadline
yeah and i don't know who's going to
want to pay him the balance of a salary
that's based on 18 million for the full
season over a million dollars a game
i just think that the ship has sailed i
feel bad saying that aj green's a great
guy he's been a great player
and you know during the summer when the
july 15 deadline came and went
i raised the question would the bengals
rescind the franchise tender
pocket 18 million in cash in a
pandemic year where the revenue is going
to be way down and carry over 18 million
in cap space for next year because
that's what you can do
like that and a day after we raised that
idea he signed his franchise tender
because once you sign it it can't be
taken away
smartest business decision he ever made
was decided because
you have to think that the bengals were
considering the possibility of removing
it and i think in hindsight based on two
games
they may be wishing they hadn't tagged
him at all and let him walk away as a
free agent and
yeah if you can trade him you trade him
and if he stays healthy
you see what's out there but who's going
to take on the balance of that salary
and it may be a situation where
it's a yannick way type of a deal where
he reduces
his remaining salary to facilitate a
trade
to a contending team for the balance of
the year all right
next question oh and let me let me chime
in on whether or not
joe burrows biggest obstacle is the
organization itself
i don't necessarily believe that i think
they're
changing i think when they pay joe mixon
market value with a year left on his
rookie contract that was a sign
that things are going to be different
when they didn't waver
in their opportunity to get joe burrow
that's a sign that things are going to
be different
and i'm hopeful that they will build out
a team around him so he can be
successful because he definitely has the
ability
he's got the drive he's got the charisma
he's got it all to be something that
they haven't had in cincinnati in a very
very long time all right dr j144
zack taylor is 2 and 16 is a head coach
he bungled the andy dalton benching last
year
kicked a field goal last night in fourth
and goal to cut it from 15 to 12.
zach didn't deserve the job to begin
with in my opinion eric the enemy
deserved the job more than him and that
makes me
sad agree or disagree shireen your
thoughts
i think eric the enemy has deserved a
job for a couple of years that he hasn't
gotten and i think he'll be a great head
coach when he does get a job which
i would assume would be in 2021 but i
thought it would be in 2020 and it
didn't happen for him but i'm not ready
to write off zach taylor yet i
i i just think he's learning to be a
head coach
and he wasn't even an offensive
coordinator with the rams and and i
think he learned a lot from mcvay i
still think he can be a great offensive
mind
he started his coaching career at a m
and i know a lot of people who know him
and think
really highly of him as an offensive
coach and think he can be really good so
i'm not ready to write him off now
the enemy might have been the better
coach the better choice
and i hope he gets a head coaching job
because he's earned it but i'm not ready
to write off zach taylor just yet
and here's the other thing to remember
about the bengals which there's no
indication that it has
changed they don't like to buy people
out
they don't like to have to pay someone
to not work for them so
whatever years of zach taylor's contract
is guaranteed
that i guarantee you means he will be
there
for that that's why the marvin lewis
firing was a surprise until we found out
2019 wasn't guaranteed so they could
walk away and not owe them anything but
they don't like to pay their head
coaches to not work so he gets some time
he's got some flexibility but he's gonna
have to do something or a second
contract is not going to happen
and yeah let's see what happens with joe
a great quarterback
can make a 2-14 coach into a much better
coach very quickly
uh once you have that guy on the field
and he starts winning games for you all
right another one from
the at pft pm posse account and this
comes
via the pftp and posse account it
originates with at nfl leads
since there are no fans attending games
what's the point of singing a national
anthem to an empty stadium when most of
the players have to make a decision
of standing or kneeling and look i i
have wondered that all along the moment
that they said there weren't going to be
fans at these games
what's the point of starting a game with
any type
of of formality you're showing up to
play a game and no one is there to
witness it they rarely
play the anthem on tv and the only way
they play it now is for the news value
of what the guys are doing
during the anthem i wouldn't have a
problem at all with not playing the
anthem before the games
um and so many of the problems we've
dealt with the past few years
we wouldn't have dealt with if they just
didn't have this ritual of playing the
national anthem
before these sporting events there's so
many things we do as a country
that don't require the playing of the
national anthem before we do it
it's just kind of odd that it became
part of sports and
uh that's what's uh led us to this point
where it becomes now this controversy
that just won't go away mike before we
ever started this controversy before
colin kaepernick ever sat down on the
bench in 2016. i wondered why we played
the anthem and and i asked it multiple
times and i don't know how it started
but you go to a play you go to a movie
wherever whatever we go to we don't
start it with the national anthem and i
know it's a big deal at the super bowl
who's going to sing the national anthem
and
we still think of whitney houston
singing the national anthem was
beautiful even if it was on
tape whatever it was still great but
there's no
to me there's no point to it i don't
know how it started i don't
care if we play it or don't play it i
don't think it's a thing of patriotism
nobody's going to miss it if you don't
play it and i love what they did by the
way
last night it was bengal brown bengal
brown and they
and they locked arms and i thought that
was really cool but again
i'm not going to miss the national
anthem if we don't have the national
anthem
and look i get it for the olympics when
the country that wins the gold medal has
its anthem played it's part of the pride
it's part of the
the notion that it's a bunch of
different nations there and whoever
wins gets that honor we don't we really
don't need it and
they say it's political when people
kneel or put a fist in the air during
the anthem the mere playing of the
anthem is a political exercise it is an
exercise enforced patriotism look
we all love our country we don't need to
go through the motions
of that before every sporting event so
that got caught up in football
and i think it's too late to try to
extricate it if they're going to play it
in an empty stadium
they're never going to stop playing it
before football games or other sporting
events shireen
yeah now it is really political now you
can't stop it because you have started
it during these protests so
we will have it empty stadium or not
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights from nbc
sports